We now note some elementary
properties of expectations.
These will be some properties
that are extremely natural and
intuitive, but even so, they
are worth recording.
The first property
is the following.
If you have a random variable
which is non-negative, then
its expected value is
also non-negative.
What does it mean that the
random variable is
non-negative?
What it means is that for all
possible outcomes of the
experiment, no matter what the
outcome is, the associated
numerical value of the
random variable is a
non-negative number.
What's the implication
of this?
When we calculate an expectation
we're adding over
all the possible numerical
values of the random variable.
All the possible numerical
values of the random variable
under this assumption
are non-negative.
Probabilities are also
non-negative.
So we have a sum of non-negative
entries and
therefore, the expected value
is also going to be
non-negative.
The next property is a
generalization of this.
Consider now a random variable
that has the property that no
matter what the outcome of the
experiment is, the value of
this random variable lies
in the range between two
constants, a and b.
In this case, we argue
as follows.
The expected value, by
definition, is a sum over all
possible values of the random
variable of certain terms.
Now, the possible numerical
values of the random variable
are all of them at least as
large as a, so this gives us
an inequality of this type.
Then, we pull a factor of a
outside of the summation.
And finally, we recall that
the sum of a PMF over all
possible values of little
x is equal to 1.
Why is that the case?
Well, these are the
probabilities for the
different numerical values
of the random variable.
The sum of the probabilities of
all the possible numerical
values has to be equal to 1,
because that exhausts all the
possibilities.
So we obtain a times
1, which is a.
So, what we have proved is that
the expected value is at
least large as a.
You can use a symmetrical
argument where the
inequalities will go the
opposite way and where a's
will be replaced by b's,
to prove the second
inequality, as well.
The last fact we want to take
note of is the following.
If we have a constant and we
take its expected value, we
obtain the same constant.
What does that mean?
We have only been talking
about expected values of
random variables.
What does it mean to take the
expected value of a constant?
Well, as we discussed earlier,
we can think of a constant as
being a random variable of
a very special type.
A random variable whose
PMF takes this form.
This random variable can take
only a single value and the
probability of that single
value is equal to 1.
This means that in the formula
for the expected value there's
going to be only one term in
this summation, and that term
is going to be c times the
probability that our random
variable takes the value c.
Now, that probability is equal
to 1, and we're left with c.
So this equality makes sense,
of course, as long as you
understand that a constant can
also be viewed as a random
variable of a very
degenerate type.
Now, intuitively, of course,
it's certainly clear
what this is saying.
That if a certain quantity is
always equal to c, then on the
average, it will also
be equal to c.